alter das ist von den beiden Folgen
Challenge accepted bisher echt das
krasseste der dreht sich die ganze Zeit
in eine Richtung
al der muss doch irgendwn mit seiner
Maus vom Tisch runter sein oder
irgendwie sowas achtet mal rechts im
Bild oh mein gott hat der
gelitten
[Musik]
blitzmenü ich habe die
Macht
[Musik]
moin kindas und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen Folge Challenge accepted
endlich mal wieder Challenge accepted ja
ich weiß es ist lange her dass die erste
Folge kam allerdings habe ich jetzt mehr
Zeit weil jetzt bald okay ich bin bald
auf Stufenfahrt habe ich eigentlich
überhaupt keine Zeit aber ich habe jetzt
gerade Zeit und deswegen wollte ich
jetzt eine Runde Challenge accepted mit
euch aufnehmen und zwar wird das sein
was ich heute mache das also ich kann
damit überhaupt nicht spielen ich komme
damit überhaupt nicht klar und also ich
ich weiß jetzt ich ma ich ma übrigens
also nicht nur das hier sondern ich ma
zudem auch noch meine
Mausempfindlichkeit hoch
auf Alter Alter Alter das istmer wie
soll ich den da W schlagen können ich
bewegt meine Maus gerade so ein
Zentimeter und so ein bisschen Alter ja
gut ich versuch das mal zu machen wir
müssen jetzt irgendwo reinkommen da
gehen wir mal rein ich weiß nicht welche
Map das ist wow wow wow wow wow ich kann
mich echt einfach mal hier so drehen
damit das so seht ich bewege meine Maus
ein paar Zentimeter und es ist komplett
wow wow also wow alter das ist so krank
Alter wow ich hoffe ich kriege hierm mit
überhaupt irgendwas auf Reihe also
Challenge accepted ist ja immer egal ich
ma so viele Runden wie es geht
hauptsache ich komme irgendwie über 10
Minuten oder so damit für euch nicht so
eine 20 Sekunden Runde sein wird oder so
damit ihr ein bisschen unterhalten
werdet
Alter ist
unnormal
wow oh mein Gott Alter ist das krank
bitte macht mal selber bevor jetzt sagt
so das ist doch gar nicht schlimm
jachann geht
los Kit ach so ein Kit ja tollrunde
kommt übrigens auch
bald was nehme ich denn ich glaube ich
nehme
einfach ich neh einfach ja komm kämpf
ein
bisschen Freunde hui Alter ich
hoffe das wird jetzt
nicht
Alter ich komme nicht mal an Kisten dran
Alter wie heftig ist das
[Musik]
denn wow wow wow Alter
wow junge Junge ist das krass
Alter man kann sich do gar nicht
schlagen oder kann man sich schon
schlagen ich weiß nicht sollen die alle
mal da hinten hinlaufen ich bleib
erstmal hier so ein bisschen kletter
hier so hoch wow wow wow Freunde also
wenn was krass ist das finde ich
definitiv schwerer als nur rechts und
links laufen aus der ersten
[Musik]
Folge Alter ist das heftig man ich komme
damit überhaupt nicht klar einige Leute
kommen damit ja klar wenn das irgendwie
so heftig ist ich weiß dass Simon das
immer relativ heftig hat aber
W also für mich ist das definitiv nichts
Alter
junge man junge ist das
heftig ich sehe auch gar nicht wie hoch
Entfernungen sind das sieht alles
unglaublich hoch
aus ich trau mich gar nicht
runterzulaufen weil ich denke mal dass D
irendwie Schaden Kriege od kriegt man
überhaupt schon boah alter das ist so
krank ich habe auch noch so ein Speed
Ding hier
[Musik]
drin Freunde Alter alter Schwede ist das
heftig Mal wenn ich sprinte wie krass
das dann
ist ich habe alles ganz ich bin der
schnellste der
wel alter das ist von den beiden Folgen
Challenge accepted bisher echt das
krasseste okay es sind das zwei Folgen
aber na ja ich hoffe mal ihr wisst was
ich meine Alter ich meist genutztes Wort
in diesem Video Alter na ja Freunde was
ich euch übrigens auch noch sagen wollte
ist mega Projekt werde ich demnächst
wieder mit anderen aufnehmen damit ich
endlich mal wieder so ein bisschen
Motivation daran bekomme weil ich bin
jetzt schon wieder Alter ich stehe auf
dem
Boden zieh das mal rein ich stehe auf
dem Boden und es sieht es ist so krass
hoch Junge ohne Witz das ist F5 und ich
bin so weit oben
ah jetzt kann ich endlich wieder normal
gehen ich habe Schuhe ich habe ein
erfahrungsfläschchen WOW leute das ist
krass da hinten ist ein
Typ wenn der jetzt hinter mir ist dann
habe ich verkackt nee doch nicht alter
Freunde das ist echt
krass hä und jetzt habe ich wieder was
ist denn das unten das ist eine Falle
einfach nee das ist nicht das sieht
schon wieder so tief aus und das sieht
so guck mal wenn ich da hoch gucke das
sieht aus W ein heftiger Berg wenn ich
so gucke sieht das aus wä es gar nichts
Alter alter das ist eine Falle ich muss
echt aufpassen wieso bin ich jetzt auf
einmal eigentlich wieder so schnell ist
das weil ich jetzt hier wieder in dem
Radius bin irgendwie von dem von der
Mitte ist das krass so ich wollte mir
erstmal das Fleisch nehmen ein bisschen
was mampfen so schön
langsamer ich kann ja so machen dann bin
ich so ungefähr wieder halb schnell mal
guck jetzt bin ich wieder schnell jetzt
bin ich ungefähr so langsam nee doch
nicht ja doch jetzt bin ich wieder
schnell blitzar will released in minutes
ach so in 2 Minuten ist dann ne in 16
Minuten ist mittelf Homos geht
weg
hilfe ich bin unglaublich schnell da war
Kiste aber ich kann es auch nicht
mehr zurück weil die da auch eine
Kiste
hä nein ich wusste dass ich das schaffe
ach mann na gut warte wir gehen wieder
zurück in die
Lobby ich glaube das war so oder ja so
war richtig so was spielen wir denn
jetzt ach das schön ich bin auf jeden
Fall nicht mehr so schnell jetzt gerade
ich häng auf jeden Fall noch eine Runde
dran das ist natürlich klar not joinable
ach mann
da los nein nein nein nein nein da nein
nein nein da will ich nicht rein hier
ist noch keiner Lobby so schnell schnell
lass mich da noch rein
los Beil
dich zack pregame Winter ach die Map
habe ich auch noch doch die haben wir
schon gespielt oder haben wir die schon
gespielt das Wasser sieht das ist gar
kein Wasser so wir nehmen diesmal ja
komm wir nehmen wieder night das hat ja
eigentlich gut geklappt nur das war halt
diese Ansicht ist halt einfach blöd in
60 Sekunden wird das Ganze
starten also mit was ich noch über euch
reden wollte ist ihr könnt jetzt in mal
in die Beschreibung gucken und zwar ist
da eine Seite drin die heißt Dinge die
ein Youtuber nicht sagt die habe ich
erstellt bei Facebook ihr kennt noch mit
sicher diese diese Seiten Dinge die ein
betrunkener nicht sagt oder Dinge die
ein Mann nicht sagt oder Dinge die ein
Gymnasiast nicht sagt oder irgendwie
sowas ich habe das mal für Youtuber
erstellt
weil immer so die Sache ist so h ich bin
erster worüber sich halt viele Youtuber
aufregen oder so h warum nur 301 Aufrufe
so solche ganzen Texte poste ich da
einfach da könnt ihr auch drauf klicken
wenn ihr kein Facebook habt die steht
immer mittig unten in der Beschreibung
da steht dann was würde ein Youtuber nie
sagen und dann ist da so ein Link und da
könnt ihr einfach drauf klicken wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr die Seite liken das wird
mich auf jeden Fall freuen nur damit ihr
wisst dass es meine Seite ist und weil
mich auch einige gefragt haben warum ich
die denn immer verlinkt
habe
ich habe gar keine
Sachen Alter wieso greifen die mich
schon
an wow wow wow ich brauche definitiv
Sachen sonst werde ich immer gar nichts
reißen
können und Leute ich bin einfach mal so
Gott gottverdammt schnell ne ja komm
schlag mich tot ja komm
du bist so ein Alter
verpiss dich los du opfer du bist so ein
verdammter Penner los geh weg ja komm
geil Killer Typ ey spti so Lobby das
sind die ganz coolen die einfach Anfang
an verfolgen ne am Anfang noch so
schönen Chat schreiben hey
concraft ja das sind die Leute weswegen
ich sowas nicht aufnehmen will äh so wo
können wir den noch mal ich möchte euch
noch eine Runde reinpacken eigentlich
äh so wo sind denn hier vernünftige da
sind zehn drin das geht
klar oh 12 so
ähm
[Musik]
m
Entschuldigung
Entschuldigung hallo geht's dir gut
m
also der dreht sich die ganze Zeit in
eine
Richtung der muss doch irgendwn mit
seiner Maus vom Tisch runter sein oder
irgendwie sowas
ist
wie okay dreht sich jetzt er dreht sich
weiter achtet mal rechts im Bild oh mein
gott hat der gelitten na gut kann ich
irgendwie drauf steigen oder so ne kann
nicht er dreht sich ert
weiter gut wenn er meint komme ich da
oben an die Kiste dran ne komme ich
nicht das von hier so nah aus sollen wir
erst weglaufen Alter die Map sieht aber
geil aus das muss man schon sagen m ist
echt geil W jetzt gerne Screenshot
machen
aber sieht einfach nur scheiße aus mit
diesem komischen jetzt sind alle blö Z
mal so hoch und so weiß nicht na ja so
das wird definitiv die letzte Runde sein
ich versuche mir direkt am Anfang Killer
Sachen zu holen ach ja Kit komm ne mal
anderes Kit nehmen
mal Range attacks ne das wird schlecht
klappen nehmen wir mal das
[Musik]
R nein da war ein holzchwert scheiße ich
bin so dumm und schnapp mir das
Holzschwert nicht
[Musik]
hey da ist schon wieder einer der ein
schlägt ja klasse Typ du bist mir
sympathisch so schnell weiter weg
[Musik]
hier dafür bin ich im Rennen relativ
gut muss man ja auch können wenn man
dann n be im kämpfen ist so weiter weg
hier
so jetzt bin ich auf einmal wieder
schnell Alter das sieht so krass aus das
ist so krank guckt euch das mal an ey
das ist doch einfach nicht mehr
normal ich bin fast h das war doch voll
tief nee war doch nicht das S nur so
tief
[Musik]
aus so wo könnten denn hier Kisten sein
Freunde sag doch mal wo könnten denn
hier Kisten sein ne ich flieg mal ein
bisschen rum das heiß fliegen
laufen also wenn ich so runter gucke
sieht das echt so aus als wä
das also ich ich kann die Entfernung
echt überhaupt nicht einschätzen also
das ist echt krass diese Challenge hier
könnt mir übrigens auch weitere
challenges wieder in die Kommentare
schreiben und dann werde ich da
eventuell da eine Kiste drauf
zurückkommen
ah man auch kein Schwert ich habe ein
Schwert ach ja wegen meinem Dings so
dann ess mal hier so ein
[Musik]
Schnitzel so dann setze ich mir meinen
Helmchen auf wie sehe ich denn jetzt aus
na gut nicht so toll
so versuch da mal so ein paar Mütter
jetzt zu oder so ach kann ich den
nicht irgendwo sind den nicht noch mehr
Kisten irgendwie irgendwo
irgendwann hier müsste auch noch eine
sein W daavon eine war da oben ist eine
da unten sind welche
ja
Killer
ja m zw noch nie gespielt aber trotzdem
schon relativ geile Sachen und jetzt
komme ich nicht mehr raus oder
was
so so ich geh mal ganz kurz nach hier
oben ach da hinten ist auch noch eine
[Musik]
Kiste
oh da ist keine Kiste also ich geh mal
ganz kurz nach oben mich zu schützen
weil ich sehe da schon kommen schon
andere so schön die Treppe
hochlaufen so muss das sein so macht das
Spaß so noch eine Kiste
yeah so da komm erstmal die hin hier
kommst du hin Schwert welches ist besser
das verzauberte mit Rückstoß 3 oder na
das verzaubert ist geiler das stimmt
natürlich dann habe ich noch
Erfahrung
bisschen was zu mampfen ja geht schon
klar ne so dann nehme ich erstmal immer
das um den Gegner dann weg zu schleudern
und dann nehm ich das andere ist H nicht
sonst noch irgendwie was da war doch
gerade auch noch eine Kiste da da in der
Mitte genau da da gehe ich jetzt auch
noch mal
[Musik]
hin ne das sind nicht so geile Sachen n
ich Brau eine Hose auf jeden Fall das
ist
wichtig ist auch noch eine Kiste da
auch so da bra ich auch
nicht ja eine
Hose so Freunde wenn ich mich anstrenge
wird das eine geile Runde aber
anstrengen und Lua kann man irgendwie
nicht in Verbindung zusammensetzen das
ist grammatikalisch überhaupt nicht
möglich kann sein dass immer wenn man
einer spielt dass man dann 30 Sekunden
Geschwindigkeit bekommt ich weiß es
nicht ich habe den dreh hier immer noch
nicht raus den
Dreh gut ich muss trotzdem jetzt neue
Spieler irgendwie finden weil ich möchte
jetzt mal irgendwi angreifen sonst ist
das ja auch wieder ein bisschen
langweilig ist unten eine Kiste schau
mal kurz da ist eine Kiste glaube ich
glaube ich kann ja wieder nichts sagen
[Musik]
ne oh mann das war ein Erdblock das ist
bitter und wieder
zurück was ist denn da hinten ich habe
optify nicht mal drin das ist halt so
bisschen das blöde ach das S ein Schiff
el players
remaining Freunde also das ist definitiv
bisher dann die beste
Runde
hallo
h m
verarschen
hä wie soll ich denn da dran kommen wenn
ich
so ach ja
so nee
hä einfach hier
so alter wollen mich
verarschen hä da ist eine Kiste und ich
komme nicht dran oder
wie
nö bin mir zu
blöd so ich habe auch eigentlich relativ
gute Sachen ne ich habe komplett fast
Eisen Dings hier wie he es modern chain
mail ich bin auf Englisch deswegen
aber bin auf
Deutsch sind die Sachen einfach ein
bisschenter Blitz da was heißt das
jetzt ach so ja ich könnte ja mal was
verzaubern
hier ach ich habe ja hier noch sogar
noch Fläschchen
ne Freunde bevor ich jetzt verzaubere
töte ich mal noch ein paar Tiere dann
bin ich Level 2 hier sind gar keine
Tiere ja okay ich verzauber einfach
direkt mit Level
1 ist ja jetzt auch egal
so Schärfe 1 ja klasse fast gar nichts
na
egal play hotck activate Blitz blit
powerfulility change of the game
okay
[Musik]
blitzmenü ich habe die
Macht
ful regenerate health attack enemy with
B blind them seconds
ach wie viele Leben eigentlich noch
sechs ja gut ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
das genau funktioniert mit dem Ding aber
ich denke wenn ein Typ kommt werde ich
den auf jeden Fall erstmal mit Rückstoß
angreifen dann mit Schärfe ein und dann
ja also auf jeden Fall muss jetzt
erstmal wieder in Mitte laufen ich habe
geile Sachen das muss man
sagen das ist irgendwie doch gut mit
dieser Ansicht also wenn man sich dran
gewöhnt hat dann dann geht das echt klar
aber auch wirklich erst wenn man sich
dran gewöhnt hat und das dauert bei mir
glaub ich
noch da unten ist
[Musik]
jemand Leute wir testen jetzt mal den
Fireball
[Musik]
hi BR
na
t so haben wir auch mal jemanden getötet
in dieser Challenge accepted
Folge ja was kann ich den jetzt
machen you needchase it ja was bringt
denn dieser scheiß der Stern wenn ich
das erstmal alles concrafter blitzninja
[Musik]
ja das hält jetzt Scheiße hätte ich das
mal doch später gemacht und außerdem
habe ich meine Rüstung an aber egal mich
sieht e jeder von daher ja ich habe die
Kiste gesehen guck mal jetzt ist die
Kiste immens
nah was heiß den unsichtbar Heß doch mal
unsichtbar
seeore
26 war so scheiße dass das jetzt schon
eingelöst
habe ach man na egal jetzt schreiben
wieder alle in die Kommentare bist so
ein
kackn sorry Bruce tut mir leid
also Youtuber jeppa
ähm jeppa
[Musik]
m wie wo sind denn jetzt Leute Mann ich
muss jetzt mal welche
[Musik]
umbringencraft das one of my favorite
wie schreibt man denn
hi ja wo seid ihr denn Leute ich muss
doch mal wen töten jetzt hier irgendwie
kann jetzt nicht malr
irgendwo
hell wo geht's denn jetzt hier als ob
das jetzt noch 9 Minuten dauert bis das
hier
losgeht ich möchte dass das jetzt schon
losgeht ich finde ja kein mehr wo sind
denn hier mal
Leute
Bad
gear so ein bisschen so die Leute
verarschen ist natürlich alles kack
Taktik
[Musik]
kaktik
ja der wird mich besiegen ach mann das
ist doch kacke mit diesem scheiß
rumgucken hier ach mist das ist das ist
echt blöd mit diesem haben uns
gegenseitig getötet nee doch nicht Alter
aber das ist echt blöd mit diesem
komischen rumgucken also ich werde das
jetzt mal eben wieder
zurückstellen
100 ach Leute ich komme mir gerade so
langsam vor irgendwie ach man ist das
geil ach Jungs hui boah cool na gut ich
würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat
dürft ihr gerne einen Daumen Hoch geben
in der Beschreibung steht die
Facebookseite Dinge die an Youtuber
nicht sagt könnt ihr auch einfach
vorbeischauen oder einfach in die
Kommentare Sachen schreiben die ich
eventuell in der nächsten Folge
Challenge accepted machen soll und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
ciao